Hey  oh [ __ ] what do I say hey back is that  lame Eamonn Hayes nice and simple stop  it's not creepy she's not gonna go back  to her friends and say oh my god you'll  never believe what beardo said what hey  yeah yeah hey safe but then what then  after hey you've got nothing remember  sweater day hey hey  weird Becky genius  step it up say something smart Oh easy  just say her name  people love hearing their name Nancy  Nancy Nancy yeah oh now she wants more  did you know you could hear with your  tongue oh I'm sorry  can you speak up ah that that is funny  that is funny um you like jokes here  weird guy Doug thank you what was that  all about  oh [ __ ] what was that old  it's pretty back see ya it's a long  number sending that to England